well it's just lying
God has blessed this video
ah what do I do do I wait it looks kind
of cool actually we've got a rainbow
how's it going bros my name is PewDiePie
and I am an epic minimalist what does
that mean I will explain
by going through 12 things I love oh
fixed it I don't like light interrupting
my video everyone
talks about minimalism as it's a it's
some kind of cure you need to have
little stuff I cure mentally you'll not
be depressed and happy now for me it's
just uh I run all these clowns on me
when I joke I'm an epic minimalist
because I have to always have a bunch of
stuff for videos Felix I am an epic
minimalist buys every single gachapon
stop judging me okay I'm not trying to
adopt the title okay I don't really care
it's just but some items I do generally
really enjoy and I want to talk about
them it would probably be a little
cringy and too personal but here we go
item number one tape measurer
do I need to say anything else tape
measure it measures
don't lie to me because I know you've
done this you bought something online
and it comes in the mail and it's either
too big or too small than you expected
never happens to me
tape measure always that hand
stays there you can borrow it but it
goes back every time God this sounds so
cringy but
tape measures are usually kind of ugly
right Google tape measure how did it
look like they look bad I'm really glad
I got a pretty one because I can keep it
out and I don't have to just keep it in
my toolbox and this is so handy to
always have it here I know it's silly
but it's one of those things where
whenever you need something measured and
you know I can literally just go and
grab it I find joy in it okay it's the
little things guys you don't get it I
read somewhere that the only way to not
lose something is to always put it back
at the same place our brains are just
not very good at remembering where we
left stuff because our Consciousness can
only focus on so many things if I start
talking and many conversations at the
same time all of a sudden you don't
understand it I like the Bing Bong the
ominous
maybe you still understood and that
wasn't my point I don't know
so if you take something and then you
focused on something else and you leave
it somewhere you lose it that's how you
lose it always keep yourself at the same
place live tag from an epic minimalist
you're welcome but you never would have
figured that one out on your own number
two shoes
I
kind of guy all these celebrities they
got all kinds of shoe collections hey
look at all my shoes cringe dumb you
dummy dumb one pair of shoe one pair of
shoe Supreme and I will explain why it's
the best way to go Marcia thinks I'm
crazy for having this rule I've been
doing it for a couple years
the thing is I know this is going to
sound bad and I oh I I hate saying it
but I will say it once you're able to
buy whatever you want kind of it's not
really that exciting anymore in the same
way as before I used to enjoy you know
saving up to things and then be feeling
excited when I when I could finally buy
it it was it was fun it was cool like I
was high I don't really get that anymore
I know boohoo I'm just saying so the way
I do it is I have one pair of shoes
because first of all why would I need
another pair of shoes okay to walk on
all fours I don't think so I wear them
till they're completely [ __ ] then when
it's time to buy new shoes it's like oh
exciting I look forward to it that's why
one pair of shoe Supreme these are the
contenders I bought these years ago I
never got to really fully wear them
because I I left them here in Japan and
then we weren't able to enter for two
and a half years but now I can wear them
and they're shoe Supreme I wear these
for everything I have three rules from
picking shoes and I cannot compromise
eyes on them whatsoever they got to be
comfortable they got to be fast to enter
if I have to sit down to enter my shoes
they're not shoes they're a burden okay
number three they gotta be versatile
obviously different weather and
different locations they gotta work
these ones look all burned out but
they're not
fashion
wow I regret putting these here yeah
they're all right I usually like to go
for really goofy shoes because I kind of
dress plainly but you know that's just
how it goes
I know it's a bit silly and I almost
feel silly talking about it but hey I
like buying new shoes when the time
comes number three today's sponsor Rhino
Shield that's right baby rhino Shields
are incredibly durable phone cases you
could do anything with these your phone
can definitely handle it Rhino Shield's
designs always come out amazing and but
I do think these is probably the best
one we've ever done this one looks so
good we took optical illusions and mixed
it with the PewDiePie pattern I love the
design it's so it looks amazing some of
them are quite
I don't know if he shows on camera but
when you look at them you're like
it's kind of cool five new designs we
also had the Japan PewDiePie Ones Still
and the regular pen and amazing durable
and stylish check out the link in the
description and if you use the code
PewDiePie you get 20 off within the
first week of this video so don't wait
but you will get 10 off if you still use
the code after that it works for other
orders as well they had recently
launched a Naruto 3D case it feels
different I don't know how to explain it
but yeah definitely can't live without
my PewDiePie Rhino Shield
listen protect your phone okay uh well I
gotta tell you this as well number four
interchangeable dumb bounds can't live
without them diogenes himself use these
very ones I've been using these type for
years I really enjoy working with
dumbbells uh space has always been kind
of limited for whatever reasons for me
when we were about to move to Japan yeah
we lived in my office and I just didn't
have space gyms were closed but I always
prefer working out at home as well and I
love working out with dumbbells you can
change
quickly to different weights
it's just a really convenient way to
work out the ultimate workout as an epic
minimalist would just be to not have the
I guess just free body weight but I
definitely owe a lot of my gains to
interchangeable dumbbells I do have a
more advanced setup here as well I've
showed it before but I still use this
all the time I think it's so it's such a
nice way to work out it's fast it's easy
it gets the job done interchangeable
dumbbells number five did you spot it
the Swiss champ I love Swiss champ I've
always looked at these multi-tools first
of all Leatherman gang you can relax I
have one downstairs in my toolbox it's
just it's just way too convenient I used
to look at these tools and just go like
why would I ever need the fish scaler
why would I ever need that but one day
someone is gonna ask hey I need a fish
scaler right a new one helped me I will
be there and I will offer you can borrow
it
and it will be glorious
the thing is uh you are surprised by how
useful it is to have something that you
almost didn't realize you had like the
other day I did need a magnifying glass
and uh I was like oh I actually have one
never mind I got you I can guarantee you
at least most of you who did this to
your dad's multi-tool when you were a
kid when you pulled out every single one
because you thought it looked cool what
do we got it's a bottle opener and
something else I'm not entirely sure no
this is a can opener with a flathead
screwdrivers as well star-shaped
screwdriver plier
scissor measure and fish scaler
saw let's go a file
big knife
and small peepee knife oh you thought it
was done
Corkscrew opener with tiny baby screw
I'm not entirely sure what this is for
but I definitely used it
and of course gotta have uh the Rope
holder
anyone got a rope holder I got you fan
don't worry it also got a pen and a
toothpick I love this thing I think what
I use the most is the it's a scissor
actually it's really strong and super
convenient love my Swiss champ it's
almost there and I'm always amazed when
I find another use for it that I didn't
expect love it number five Can you spot
it
as an epic minimalist that's right all
black t-shirts I'm wearing the tsuki one
I don't know if you can even see it it's
made from me and my sister's company
tsuki it's an ethically based fashion
brand with high quality I've been
wearing this one for years now and it
feels exactly the same as when it was
new and it feels really comfy
I also have the exact same pairs of
underwear eight of them and same thing
with socks same socks I did this because
I had shipped all my clothing to Japan
and I needed t-shirts and I thought I'll
just get underwear and I'll just get a
new pair of underwear and socks as well
but the thing is what I realized just
how nice it is to have the exact same
brand of everything because let's get
real here and I don't lie to me about
this we all have that one pair of
underwear that you don't want to wear
because today they look stupid or
they're just not comfortable
but you have to wear them because
eventually you run out of underwear and
you don't want to do laundry yet so you
cope so you just do what you got to do
but you feel uncomfortable the entire
day that does not happen to me same
pairs of underwear no wait I don't have
eight different pairs but same brand you
owe it to yourself and to your junk to
always be comfortable same with your
feet see I obviously you used to lose
socks I had funky socks thinking hey huh
that's quirky you lose one and then it's
done I can't be bothered with that plus
the best part of all of it is of course
laundry is extremely simple
it just makes my life a little easier I
also read this thing about you probably
heard that see a lot of CEOs wear the
same kind of outfits just because it
saves them another decision to make that
day I always find that to be really
silly and stupid but it is true we have
uh something in our brain called oh it's
decision fatigue so even if something is
a simple decision like picking your
outfit it's still a decision that you're
making and the more decisions you make a
day the more fatigue you will have and
it not only makes you make less good
decisions it also tires you out
throughout the day I've definitely had
this at a couple times in my life
especially over silly things I remember
one time someone literally just asked if
I wanted coffee and I was so tired that
I was just like ah
just leave me alone
so maybe I'm just more sensitive to it
it's not the reason I wear the shirts by
the way it's just a something I observed
uh I literally just because it's
comfortable and I just find it more
practical but yeah who knows try it out
you might like it I've lost count but
next item
my watch as an epic minimalist it's kind
of hard to justify having a watch to
begin with because literally you could
just check the time on your phone right
but it it's just way too convenient to
be like hey what day is it 26 oh got you
hey what time is it the big one is
quarter to three see how much faster
that was
when I moved to Japan I looked into I
wanted a Japanese watch and I had looked
into the Brian Grand Seiko Japan's
craftsmanship especially with watches is
just incredible I just fell in love with
the design on this one it's a 62 GS it
doesn't have the famous Spring Drive it
has a high beat 36 000 so it beats 10
times per second it almost sounds wrong
when I say it but that's actually it
yeah 10 times per second so it's
extremely smooth and I'll get a better
shot of it why do you need that no
reason really
it's just it's just more precise I guess
a lot of times when Watchers beat more
rapidly sorry I don't know all the watch
term but basically they they can't run
for as long but this one with the
technology that it has of the whatever
drive it has it still lasts for a long
time since I only have one watch I wear
it for anything if I go surfing I wear
it but I also like that I can what you
know kind of spruce up my outfit a
little bit I kind of wear very simple
clothing most of the time so I like that
it's in every occasion watch it isn't
really but I wear it as it because it
can definitely handle it I used to have
the Submariner which had a a spinny
bezel I think it's called so you can
watch two time zones which I honestly
kind of Miss because yeah there's so
many times I'm like what's the time in
Sweden right now or what's the time in
UK and then yeah so maybe I'll I'll
change for a different one in the future
but for now I really love this one uh
it's such a nice design I really love it
it's from the Heritage collections uh 62
GS if you're looking into one I used to
have a smart watch which I thought was
amazing the problem I have with it and I
everything I said in this video don't
take it too seriously because I don't
really care that much but I will tell
you anyway I just think smart watches
looks kind of ugly because what happens
is when you're not using it it's just
black all right and every smart watch it
ends up looking like any other smart
watch and it but in the promotions they
have these all these like cool dials and
stuff like yeah look at my smart watch
but in reality no it's just a black
screen most of the time and it looks bad
in my opinion as much as I did love my
Garmin Delta Max rest in peace I sold
you the grand Seiko is my Supreme watch
for now I love this thing as an epic
minimalist I approve next up
my figurines got the Gary basement
original 94 out of 100 I think I was
ahead of uh the curve on this one I just
really love the art I tried looking up
online and you can't really get them
anymore everyone I've seen online has
been fake so yeah that's kind of cool I
did a video on all my figurine
collections but this is the only one I
actually bothered shipping over to Japan
along with the Unicorn you see in the
back but we of course have the Ikea
Gundam as well uh this is a
yeah I keep showing this off because I'm
so proud of it it's a fully custom build
that I did and I am not a very precise
person I'm more or less God damn it I'm
more about let's put everything together
it'll be fine uh but I really took my
time with this project and it kind of a
lot taught me the satisfaction of you
know not skipping out on details is
probably took me like 20 to 30 hours to
build and because you had to sand down
every single piece you have to prime it
you have to paint it twice and then top
coat it and then assemble it and then
put the put the decals obviously it's a
lot
but I'm just so stoked with how it came
out and uh you know I had a lot of
figurines and because I took so much
time with it and I'm so happy with the
result it's just something I'm actually
really proud of and yeah it would be
really difficult for me to get rid of
this one I love the Toby one as well I
think for me with the with the Epic
minimalist meme it's it's not to me
necessarily about having as few things
as possible although with some
exceptions like shoes and watches but
it's about finding the things that you
really like and actually treasuring them
in a different way kind of changes my
relationship with certain items and you
take better care of them for them to
last longer and other things like that
as well so it's more appreciating the
things you have rather than just having
a bunch of stuff that you maybe don't
even realize you own I don't know
everyone's different this is I just know
this is how I am and yeah it's kind of
funny I realized most of the stuff I'm
talking about is literally in this video
my books
epic minimalist I can't really justify
having books it doesn't make any sense
it's impractical I have the option to
read digitally and sometimes I do I feel
like reading books is almost if I really
enjoy it at least it's almost a very a
personal experience and for me to even
just look at the books title or back
cover again it's just something I enjoy
to see it's kind of hard to explain or
if there's something I want to look up
in one of the books it's nice to have it
so quick and ready there are some nicer
books that I have that are actually
quite rare I guess the the Sun and steel
it's just like I don't think they print
this anymore so it kind of feels weirdly
important to own if that makes sense I
also have a really old edition of The
Iliad and the Odyssey which I'm very
proud of Elliott is probably one of my
favorite books ever written highly
recommend reading it I guess I'm not an
epic minimalist after all like I know it
doesn't make sense I just enjoy having
them I don't keep every single book I
read but most of the book books I keep I
feel like there's at least something
that I can share about them that I found
useful or interesting at least and I
feel like that with most of these was it
number 12 now I think I've gone over
my knife
I'm still not very good at it but it
just I love I love I love flipping the
fake balustion knife
it's just so satisfying I can't tell you
how much I love it
it's something about how do I explain it
okay so I remember I wanted to do this
flip
and I thought it was impossible
I just couldn't wrap my head around it
but I kept trying and I kept trying
and you think you're not making any
progress but then eventually you got it
and it's so weird to me how you can
learn something without thinking it
muscle memory yes
this is very satisfying to get that
direct seeing that instant Improvement I
think I mean that's why people like
video games right you see that instant
Improvement and there's something very
satisfying about that in my opinion
and it just feels so good in your hands
when you're doing it I know how that
sounds okay
I love it where was I before I had the
ballet song I don't know I don't know if
it's an anxiety thing or if it's a ADHD
thing I don't think it is I just I just
enjoy it
okay don't psychoanalyze me last but not
least it's been here all this time my
wedding ring my most precious item of
all if there's one thing I will keep for
the rest of my life is this one I've got
it at a local shop here in Japan I don't
know if there's that much to say about
it it's a ring but it's an item I have
that I will always truly treasure you
know and I think that's not necessarily
A Bad Thing even for an epic minimalist
I hope this video is enjoyable let me
know if it was because I feel really
weird and I'll see you guys in the next
one bye bye this is my gamer setup